[Music]
thank you
hi guys it's Quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the YouTube algorithm
really notices me
[Music]
in this video I'll be explaining the
three body problem series with minimal
spoilers the three body problem is the
first book in a series of science
fiction books called the remembrance of
Earth's past by shishin Liu the three
body problem was originally published in
Chinese in 2008 and was republished in
English in 2014. the following books the
Dark Forest and death's Inn were also
translated and published in English in
the two years following the original
English publication of the first
I've described this book series as one
of the scariest that I've ever read but
I don't mean scary in a traditional
sense it's more existentially terrifying
because of the questions that it brings
up about the nature of our universe and
about what the potential answers to
these questions say about our place in
it I also enjoy the fact that these
books were written by a Chinese author
because it provides a unique cultural
perspective that is dissimilar to what
we typically see in Western science
fiction it is a series that keeps you on
your toes and keeps you guessing as to
what will happen next
the book follows a few different
characters as human society evolves and
changes following the Revelation that an
alien race from beyond the stars has set
its eyes upon the Earth and would arrive
within the span of several hundred years
we get to witness as various humans
react to this knowledge in different
ways and we also get to see the movement
of the human organism as a whole a very
interesting fact about human society is
that sometimes we act as a super
organism an organism that is independent
of any individual this series does a
good job of highlighting this fact
the concept of cosmic sociology is also
a big part of these books if alien life
exists
then what is society amongst different
races of alien beings like
was it actually anything like we
typically dreamed of in our science
fiction the optimism of Star Trek the
multi-species worlds of Star Wars was
interspecies Galactic Civilization even
a possibility or was the reality of
cosmic Society more terrible than we
ever could have imagined the exploration
of these ideas is at the center of this
book series
as the books go on humankind begins to
understand previously unknown facts
about the current and former nature of
the universe the universe was in fact
riddled with Cosmic Secrets waiting to
be uncovered the series eventually
proposes a potential solution to the
famous Fermi Paradox which asks the
question if life in the cosmos based on
what we currently know should be
relatively common then why don't we see
said life
the dark and Silent universe itself acts
as an ominous backdrop to the series at
all times invoking the question
what is out there
as the books go on we begin to uncover
facts about the multi-dimensionality of
space
what was beyond the third dimension
could life exist in the second dimension
these books are also about the legacy of
humankind nothing is permanent
everything eventually dies but what do
we leave behind will we survive the
destruction of our son will we as a
species outlive our own solar system
can we contend with the harshness of the
cosmos itself and the reality of cosmic
Society
these books are Journey
and I can almost guarantee you that once
you read them you won't be able to stop
thinking about them for weeks or even
months
alright so there you go the three body
problem series remembrance of Earth's
past with minimal spoilers
tell me how I did if you enjoyed the
video consider hitting the like button
peace out
[Music]
foreign
[Music]